[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka
guten Abend das langjährige
Regierungschefs nach ihrer Amtszeit
Orden und andere Würdigungen erhalten
ist durchaus üblich zumindest wenn sie
sich nicht gerade umgehend in die Arme
russischer Gaskonzerne geworfen haben
oder durch einen Spendenskandal zur
Personal und Grad haben so etwas gibt es
bei Angela Merkel nicht an ihrer
Integrität äußerst niemand äußert
niemand Zweifel was wahrlich nicht
gering zu schätzen ist wie aber ihre 16
Jahre Kanzlerschaft insgesamt zu
bewerten sind darüber gehen die
Meinungen auseinander auch in ihrer
eigenen Partei und vielleicht wird man
vieles erst mit größeren zeitlichen
Abstand einordnen können
doch Bundespräsident Steinmeier befand
dass die Bundeskanzlerin ad bereits
heute den höchsten Verdienstorden
erhalten soll den er verleihen kann
darüber berichtet Diana zimmermann
die Geehrte selbst hatte entschieden wer
mit ihr feiern durfte heute im Schloss
Bellevue darunter der Kanzler die
kommissionspräsidentin Jürgen Klinsmann
auffällig niemand aus der aktuellen
CDU-Spitze der Bundespräsident freute
sich so sagte er Angela Merkel mit
diesem ausnahmeorden zu Ehren für ihre
außergewöhnlich lange Amtszeit für ihren
außergewöhnlichen politischen Lebensweg
auf dem sie die Erfahrung in der
Diktatur so überzeugend einsetzten für
die Stärkung der Demokratie es war ein
ganz eigenes Schauspiel bei dem der
ehemalige Außenminister seine ehemalige
Chefin mit dem höchsten Verdienstorden
auszeichnete zuvor hatte er ihre
russland-politik ein bisschen verteidigt
und seine gleich mit
Putins russland hat die europäische
sicherheitsordnung in Frieden auf
unserem Kontinent für den Sie wie viele
ihrer Vorgänger im Kanzleramt Jahre und
jahrzehntelang gearbeitet haben in
Schutt und Asche gelegt heute müssen wir
anders denken
an das Handeln
die Kritik an Angela Merkel ist seit
ihrem Abgang immer lauter geworden die
Republik scheint aufgewacht aus der
Alternativlosigkeit die sie predigte und
stellt fest das Land war abhängig von
Moskau und ist es immer noch von Peking
die Energiewende wurde verschleppt die
Kinderarmut ist in der Zeit dramatisch
gestiegen die soziale Ungleichheit hat
zugenommen fast herzlich tönt ist
dagegen von den Grünen man muss nicht
mit ihrem gesamten politischen Wirken
einverstanden zu sein um ihren hohen
Verdienst um unser Land anzuerkennen und
diesem Sinne gratuliere ich Angela
Merkel süße Hunde Auszeichnung
ausgerechnet ihre eigene Partei aber die
Merkel 16 Jahre lang zur
Regierungspartei gemacht hat tut sich
schwer in dem Orden der nach Konrad
Adenauer und Helmut Kohl erst zum
dritten Mal verliehen wird etwas Gutes
abzugewinnen heute bekommt der Frau
Merkel diesen höchsten Orden als dritte
CDU-Kanzlerin erfüllt sie das mit Stolz
wir haben das als
Bundesvorstand und auch ich als
Parteivorsitzender nicht zu bewerten und
zu beurteilen das ist die souveräne
Entscheidung des Bundespräsidenten und
es ist die souveräne Entscheidung von
Frau Merkel wer heute Abend dazu
eingeladen wird nicht mal ein
Glückwunsch kam Friedrich Merz über die
Lippen der CDU-Vorsitzende wollte
darüber sprechen was für eine Partei die
seine nun sein will sein soll um wieder
Kanzlerpartei zu werden dazu waren die
CDU-Mitglieder befragt worden und März
sieht sich bestätigt 55% von ihnen
bereuen den unter der Kanzlerin
begonnenen Atomausstieg eine überragende
Mehrheit will eine deutlich restriktive
Flüchtlingspolitik
die Partei lebt die Partei arbeitet die
Partei diskutiert mit die Partei denkt
mit und das ist genau der Prozess den
wir jetzt angestoßen haben die Kritik an
der Vorgängerin auch hier kaum zu
überhören Angela Merkel übrigens Tat in
ihrer Rede nichts als jedem ihrer Gäste
einzeln zu danken es wird ja oft
gesprochen was für eine Schlangengrube
Politik ist ich darf sagen ich hätte es
nicht überlebt wenn es nicht auch die
andere Seite der Politik gibt und
deshalb konnte ich mir auch immer Freude
machen danke schön Herr Bundespräsident
der Orden für die Kanzlerin darüber
waren wir mit einem Mann sprechen der
Angela Merkel seit ihrem Amtsantritt
sehr genau beobachtet hat die bisher
umfänglichste Biografie über sie
geschrieben der Historiker und
faz-kollege Ralf Bollmann guten Abend
Herr Bollmann guten sich die
Veranstaltung heute Abend in Bellevue
ansieht was ja direkt ins Auge fällt ist
wer nicht da ist ja Angela Merkel hat
die Einladungsliste glaube ich ganz
konsequenten nach der Frage gestaltet
wer hat ihr geholfen in ihrer
politischen Karriere der war eingeladen
oder die wer hat versucht zu verhindern
dass sie ins Kanzleramt kommt die Leute
waren nicht eingeladen dazu gehört
beispielsweise der jetzige
CDU-Vorsitzende Friedrich Merz ja das
fällt natürlich ins Auge dass der nicht
da man hätte ihn natürlich schon
einladen können er ist immerhin der Chef
der Partei der sie ja nun auch angehört
und die sie ja auch letztendlich ins
Kanzleramt mitgebracht hat
Merkel hat bei ihrem ersten Auftritt
nach dem Ende der Amtszeit Folgen Sommer
gesagt sie macht jetzt nur noch
wohlfühltermine und ich glaube das
gehört auch ein bisschen in die
Kategorie dass die Leute mit denen sie
sich aus ihrer Sicht in der Amtszeit
lange genug rumgeärgert hat dass sie die
dass sie sozusagen sich das nicht mehr
antun muss gehört für sie glaube ich zu
den Segnungen der nach Amtszeit aber es
gibt ja einen ganz offensichtlichen
graben oder eine Entfremdung zwischen
ihr und ihrer Parteien
ja ich glaube dass ihr da aber aus
Teilen ihrer Partei ich würde nicht
sagen die Partei was Teilen ihrer Partei
auch Unrecht getan wird schauen Sie sich
mal an wie die Mitte rechts Parteien
überall sonst in Europa aussehen
teilweise gibt's die gar nicht mehr
teilweise haben die Wahlergebnisse um
die 5 %. ich glaube schon dass Merkels
versucht die politische Mitte zu erobern
der jetzt ja sehr kritisiert wird von
manchen in der Partei dass der dazu
beigetragen hat dass es die CDU als
große Partei heute überhaupt noch gibt
ja die Kritik aus der eigenen Partei aus
der CDU CSU macht sich ja fest vor allem
am Abend am Atomausstieg und an der
flüchtlingskrise
2015/2015 das sind wiederum Punkte die
andere dann und man es fällt ja auf dass
SPD und Grüne sich heute sehr loben und
über diese Amtszeit der Kanzlerin äußern
die anderen dann eher wieder als
besonders positiv in Erinnerung bleibt
ja Angela glaube ich tatsächlich immer
konsequent versucht auch die politische
Mitte zu erobern ich fand ja interessant
wenn Sie fragen wer denn da war heute
dass der amtieren der Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz gekommen ist weil er glaube ich
dadurch genau dieses Unterfangen die
politische Mitte zu besetzen sozusagen
erreichen will dass er merke sich in die
Kontinuität Merkels stellt trotz aller
Kritik die sie jetzt auseinander Merkel
gibt und versucht der CDU das sozusagen
jetzt auch ein Stück weit wegzunehmen
nun merkt aber auch gerade die
ampelregierung wird ja auch nicht müde
ist zu betonen das ist dann nach diesen
16 Jahren Merkel den eigentlich auch
nicht alleine regierte sondern lange
Zeit in große Koalition ein erheblichen
Reformstau in verschiedenen Bereichen
unseres Landes gibt ja unbedingt
Merkel hat zweimal versucht wirklich was
zu verändern das Land
veränderungsbereiter mobiler offener zu
machen das eine waren die großen
Wirtschaftsreformen mit denen Sie die
Wahl 2005 fast verloren hätte ihre erste
Wahl zur Kanzlerin das zweite war
tatsächlich die Flüchtlingspolitik die
2015 sie fast das Amt gekostet hätte und
ich glaube für sie war tatsächlich die
Konsequenz daraus zu sagen die Deutschen
also sogar fast sagen naja verachten ist
zu viel gesagt aber dass sie doch ein
eher negatives Bild der deutschen in
ihrer Mehrheit hatte als
wohlstandsverwöhnt wenig
veränderungsbereit und dass sie davor
letztendlich kapituliert hat man fällt
ja auf wer ihr heute auch diesen Orden
verliehen hat und es war ja auch seine
Entscheidung Bundespräsident Steinmeier
man könnte jetzt fast sagen bisschen
sagen sich selbst hatte damit auch ein
Stück weit ausgezeichnet immerhin war er
acht Jahre ihr Außenminister und beide
müssen sich heute den Vorwurf gefallen
lassen die eine gemeinsame
Russlandpolitik gemacht zu haben wobei
ich glaube das ist tatsächlich ein
entscheidenden Unterschied zwischen
Merkel und Steinmeier gibt nicht nur der
Standard sich entschuldigt hat und
Merkel nicht sondern insbesondere das
Angela Merkel immer wusste wie
gefährlich putin ist also Merkels
Vorsicht im Umgang mit Russland lag
daran dass sie Angst vor putin hatte bei
Steinmeier Wasser in der ersten Amtszeit
so dass er sehr viel Verständnis für
Russland hatte dass er als Außenminister
sogar eine einige Konflikte im Umgang
mit Merkel hatte weil er fand dass sie
autoritäre Regime wie in Russland und
China zu hart anfasst das hat ihm
überhaupt nicht gepasst näher
zusammengekommen sind beide dann erst in
der krim-krise 2014 wo Merkel da muss
man auch mal erinnern sehr stark
kritisiert worden ist für dafür dass sie
überhaupt Sanktionen gegen Russland
gemacht hat große Teile der deutschen
Wirtschafts Elite beispielsweise waren
davon ja überhaupt nicht begeistert wir
wollten das nicht aber das was man heute
als Härte gegenüber Russland bezeichnet
oder hat sie auch nicht gemacht also
wieder hat sie dann die Bundeswehr
aufgerüstet und zu sagen wir müssen dann
Zeichen setzen und und containen wie man
das neudeutsch sagt noch hat sie etwas
gegen die Energiepolitik die ja nicht
nur von der SPD vorangetrieben wurde
getan also vor allen Dingen Nordstr 2
hat sie ja nach und sogar noch nach der
Annektion der Krim und der Besetzung der
Ostukraine noch befürwortet oder nicht
aufgehalten das ist natürlich ein sehr
interessanter Punkt weil das glaube ich
wirklich sehr bezeichnet ist für Merkels
Regierungsstil sie war eine Ministerin
im Umgang mit den großen internationalen
Krisen und ich würde sagen Merkels
Außenpolitik in diesen Fragen zum
Beispiel der
minskervertrag von 2015 den ja
Steinmeier in seiner Ansprache heute
auch verteidigt hat das waren Dinge die
sehr nachvollziehbar waren würde ich
sagen auch aus heutiger Sicht noch die
Probleme lagen ja genau da wo es in
politisch schwierig geworden wäre wenn
Sie auf das russische Gas verzichtet
hätte hätte sie natürlich die
Energiewende richtig vorantreiben müssen
wir sehen ja jetzt gerade
Stichwort heizen beispielsweise wie
konfliktträchtig das im Umgang mit der
Bevölkerung ist übrigens auch mit der
Industrie diese Konflikte wollte sie
nicht eingehen genauso bei der
Bundeswehr ganz schwieriges Thema im
Inland Reform unfähig schwierig die
Leute wollen kein Geld fürs Militär das
hat sie sich auch nicht getraut
ernsthaft anzupacken dafür muss das
jetzt nachgeholt werden Herr Bollmann
danke für das Gespräch an diesem Abend
putin ist war eigentlich nicht zu
übersehen allein die vielen politischen
Morde und politischen Häftlinge in
Russland Wiesen frühzeitig die Richtung
2006 die Journalistin Anna politowska ja
die sich zu sehr für die Hintergründe
des tschetschenienkriegs interessiert im
gleichen Jahr der infame
polonium-anschlag in London auf den
Ex-Agenten
die Liste ließe sich lange fortsetzen
ein besonderer Schlag gegen die
russische Opposition war die Erschießung
von Boris nennsdorf 2015 er hätte Putin
wohl am ehesten gefährlich werden können
heute wurde in Moskau einer seiner
engsten Freunde verurteilt der
Kremlkritiker karamusa Nina Niebergall
berichtet
am Abend vor dem beispiellosen Urteil
treffen sich noch einmal
moskauskritische intellektuelle
zumindest die die noch übrig sind das
sacharow-zentrum muss schließen nachdem
die Behörden dem Kulturhaus die Miete
gekündigt hatten für mien eine der
letzten Bastionen der Freiheit der
freien Meinungsäußerung
alle werden gleichgeschaltet müssen das
Gleiche denken alle müssen mobilisiert
werden denn das Land führt einen Krieg
und zu Kriegszeiten müssen alle
geschlossen auftreten andernfalls wird
es schlecht werden so denkt das Regime
wenn jemand ausschert wird das als
Verrat und als eine feindselige Handlung
angesehen
wie zum Beweis am Morgen danach Wladimir
karamursawe zu strenger Lagerhaft
verurteilt 25 Jahre die härteste je
verhängte Strafe für einen politischen
Gefangenen vor wenigen Tagen seine
letzten Worte vor Gericht ich sitze
wegen meiner politischen Ansichten im
Gefängnis weil ich mich gegen den Krieg
in der Ukraine ausgesprochen habe weil
ich jahrelang gegen Putins Diktatur
gekämpft habe ich bereue nicht nur
nichts von alledem ich bin stolz darauf
festgenommen wurde er nach einer Rede
vor dem Senat im US-Bundesstaat Arizona
heute sieht die Welt was das
putin-regime der Ukraine antut die
Streubomben auf Wohngebiete auf
Entbindungsstationen Krankenhäuser und
Schulen das sind Kriegsverbrechen die
von dem diktatorischen Regime im Kreml
begangen werden
diese Worte für Putins Regime
Falschinformationen eine Straftat später
kommt der Vorwurf Hochverrat dazu
jahrelang kämpfte karamursar gegen
staatliche Willkür an der Seite von
alexena balny und Boris nimmt so auf der
2015 erschossen wird in den Jahren
danach zwei Giftanschläge auf karamusa
Russlands Opposition ist weitgehend
ausgeschaltet wenn nicht schon tot ist
oder das Land verlassen hat sitzt hinter
Gittern für politische Häftlinge Wiener
walnie bedeutet das immer wieder
einzelarrest sein Gesundheitszustand
verschlechtert sich zunehmend
ist nervenkrank seit den giftanschlägen
die lange Haft könnte sein Todesurteil
sein
Entsetzen heute bei einem der letzten
Oppositionellen der in Russland noch auf
freiem Fuß ist
dieses Urteil ist nur noch mit der Zeit
Stalins vergleichbar besonders
ungeheuerlich ist die Tatsache dass es
eine Strafe für Worte ist das zeigt
deutlich dass die Behörden sogar Angst
vor Worten haben
im sacharow-zentrum haben sie zum
Abschied ein Lied gesungen über Liebe
Trauer und Zusammenhalt in Gedenken an
die Menschenrechte die in Russland zu
Grabe getragen werden
östliche Regierungen äußerten sich
empört über das Urteil das putinistische
Russland und das ist ja nicht nur der
eine man an der Spitze ist aber ja nicht
die einzige Gefahr der sich die
westliche Staatengemeinschaft
gegenübersieht bei der Konferenz der G7
Außenminister heute steht mindestens
noch ein anderer Elefant im Raum China
insofern passt es das hier treffen
diesmal in Asien stattfindet in Japan
von dort berichtet Andreas kühners
es muss einen Grund geben aus dem Japan
das g7-treffen an den Fuß des asama
Vulkans gelegt hat in den Urlauberort
caroizawa eine schnellzugstunde von
Tokio entfernt der Asamer qualmt heute
ein bisschen er soll innerlich kochen
aber eigentlich nicht zu
ausbrüchenneigen
Joschi Masa hayashi ist g7-präsident in
eruptiven Zeiten er hat seinen sechs
Ministerkollegen für jeden Tag eine
großkrise auf die Tagesordnung
geschrieben je einen politischen Vulkan
gestern China heute Russland morgen
Nordkorea
hayashi soll nicht so Ausbrüchen neigen
selbst wenn er innerlich kocht
die internationale Staatengemeinschaft
steht an einem Wendepunkt der Geschichte
wir werden jegliche Versuche
zurückweisen den Status Quo mit Gewalt
zu ändern
es soll der Wert dieser Treffen sein das
extrem offen gesprochen wird Handys
müssen im Nebenraum weggeschlossen
werden es darf gebranntstormt es soll
gestritten es muss vertraut werden
selbst einige der engsten Beraterinnen
dürfen nicht rein
nach außen inszeniert sich die Gruppe
der sieben als eingeschworenes Team dass
ich nicht spalten lasse so sehr ist die
Präsidenten Putin und hi auch versuchten
immer wieder wird beteuert
dass wir im g7-kreis nicht nur als
wertepartner eng zusammenstehen sondern
uns auch menschlich über die letzten
anderthalb Jahre wirklich nahe kommen
sind und gerade in solchen Zeiten sollte
man dieses Vertrauen die Menschlichkeit
miteinander nicht unterschätzen wie viel
Vertrauen wie viel Menschlichkeit es im
russisch chinesischen Team gibt es
schwer zu sagen vielleicht ist
pekingsverteidigungsminister gerade
zufällig für vier Tage in Moskau aber
der ständig wiederholte Hinweis auf die
militäre technische Zusammenarbeit ist
Absicht
ich denke dass dies zweifellos ein
weiterer wichtiger Bereich ist der den
exklusiven und vertrauten Charakter
unserer Beziehungen der Beziehungen
zwischen der Russischen Föderation und
der Volksrepublik China stärkt
die G7 sagen der Ukraine eine
Fortsetzung der bisherigen Militärhilfe
zu und zusätzliche Mittel für die
Energieinfrastruktur an
niemand weiß
wann der an dem Russland
sprechen aber wir als G7 tun alles dafür
dass die Ukraine dann so stark da steht
dass sie frei über ihre Zukunft
entscheiden kann dann stehen im leicht
frisurfeindlichen Frühlingswind von
carouizava die G7 plus die EU und wer
weiß wo er hingucken muss kann im
Hintergrund den Rauch aus dem Vulkan
aufsteigen sehen
und mit einem anderen großen Thema der
Weltgemeinschaft geht es bei dir jetzt
eine Nachrichten weiter Heinz der
Expertenrat für Klimafragen hat es jetzt
bestätigt Deutschland hat 2022 weniger
Treibhausgase ausgestoßen als im Jahr
zuvor allerdings sei dieser Rückgang
teilweise krisenbedingt gewesen durch
die hohen Energiepreise und das
geringere Wirtschaftswachstum wie die
Experten in ihrem heute vorgestellten
Bericht feststellten skeptisch sieht der
Rat eine mögliche Aufweichung der
sektorenziele also das beispielsweise
verfehlte Klimaziele eines Ministeriums
durch ein anderes Ministerium
ausgeglichen werden können
wir sehen eigentlich dass wir in keinem
Sektor wirklich auf einem guten Weg sind
und das heißt auch wenn wir aggregiert
betrachten ist das nicht so dass ein
Sektor dem anderen was ausleihen könnte
Deutschland hat sich das Ziel gesetzt
seine Ausstoß an Treibhausgasen bis 2030
um 65 Prozent im Vergleich zum Jahr 1990
zu senken
nach Inkrafttreten der umstrittenen
Rentenreform hat der französische
Präsident Emmanuel macron in einer
Fernsehansprache erklärt dass er den
Zorn der Demonstrierenden vernommen habe
aber auch den Willen die
Arbeitsbedingungen zu verbessern er
wurde Gespräche mit Gewerkschaften an
und bekräftigte dass die Reformen
notwendig gewesen sei um die Rente für
alle zu sichern
Brandenburgs Bildungsministerin Britta
Ernst SPD tritt zurück als Grund nannte
Ernst fehlende Unterstützung der
SPD-Landtagsfraktion für ihre Vorschläge
zur Verteilung von Lehrkräften und der
Umwandlung von stellen sie hatte das Amt
vor rund fünfeinhalb Jahren übernommen
Britta ernst ist die Ehefrau von
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
im Sudan gehen die Gefechte zwischen der
Armee und einer rivalisierenden Miliz
weiter bei den seit Samstag andauernden
Kämpfen sollen mindestens 180 Menschen
getötet und etwa 1.800 verletzt worden
sein und Beobachter befürchten die Lage
könnte sich noch verschlimmern wenn
weitere bewaffnete Gruppen im Land in
den Konflikt eingreifen
die Gase und Strompreise für Verbraucher
sind im zweiten Halbjahr 2022 erneut
stark gestiegen vor allem Gas wurde
deutlich teurer wie der Statistische
Bundesamt mit den heute vorgelegten
Berechnungen bestätigt von der Rückschau
jetzt zu den Aussichten Frank Bethmann
wie wird die weitere Entwicklung der
Preise eingeschätzt kurzfristig dürften
die Verbraucherpreise für Gas und Strom
hoch bleiben das mag den ein oder
anderen Wunder denn die Stadtwerke und
andere Versorger kaufen Gas und Strom
inzwischen bereits wieder zu deutlich
niedrigeren Preisen ein als noch vor
einem halben Jahr preissünden für
Verbraucher sind aber dennoch nicht in
sich das liegt vor allem daran dass die
privaten Haushalte ihre Verträge
normalerweise für einen längeren
Zeitraum abschließen und so geht die
Bundesnetzagentur davon aus dass die
Kunden erst in sechs bis zwölf Monaten
von den sinkenden Preisen am Großmarkt
profitieren werden
das ist die Situation der privaten
Verbraucher wie sieht es bei der
Industrie aus ja schwierig weiterhin
schwierig muss man sagen Energie war
schon immer teuer in Deutschland und
damit ein wichtiger Kostenfaktor zwar
ist der Gaspreis an den Spot Märkten
also dort wo Unternehmen auch
kurzfristig Gas kaufen können kräftig
gefallen doch dort decken die wenigsten
Firmen ihren Gasbedarf die Mehrheit
schließt langfristige Verträge ab ganz
einfach um die Sicherheit zu haben dass
man das Gas in ausreichenden Mengen dann
auch bekommt und wer im vergangenen Jahr
zu hohen Preisen abgeschlossen hat der
erfährt kaum Entlastung es sei denn er
nimmt die Gase und Strompreis Bremsen
Anspruch die allerdings ihre Tücken hat
unter anderem müssen gewinnen Rückgänge
dokumentiert und begründet werden was
wiederum das eine oder andere
Unternehmen abschrecken dürfte ST
Petermann vielen Dank
die Hannover Messe findet nach
corona-einschränkungen zum ersten Mal
seit 2019 wieder in vollem Umfang statt
Bundeskanzler Scholz machte am Vormittag
den traditionellen Rundgang Partnerland
der Industrieschau ist in diesem Jahr
Indonesien zu den zentralen Themen der
Messe zählen etwa Wasserstoff und
Brennstoffzellentechnologie
CO2-neutrale Produktionsweisen und
künstliche Intelligenz
die italienische Polizei hat vor der
Küste Siziliens eine der größten
Drogenfunde in der Geschichte des Landes
verzeichnet etwa zwei Tonnen Kokain mit
einem geschätzten Marktwert von mehr als
400 Millionen Euro schwammen
zusammengebunden und wasserdicht
verpackt im Meer es wird vermutet dass
sie dort von Drogen schmuggeln abgeholt
und dann Land gebracht werden sollten
sommerfilme sind eigentlich eine
französische Spezialität das
französische Kino hat da unvergessene
Werke und flirrende Szenen
hervorgebracht Romy Schneider und allern
Delon am Swimmingpool der mörderische
Sommer mit Isabella Johnny oder Francois
Jule und Jim und ihre Beziehung zu giano
und immer wieder Filme von Eric Omer
Pauline am Strand oder Sommer
von ihnen ließ sich der deutsche
Regisseur Christian Petzold inspirieren
für seinen neuen Film roter Himmel ein
Sommer am Ostseestrand zwei bzw drei
Männer eine Frau diese Woche kommt der
in die Kinos Nadja nasser hat den sich
angesehen
[Musik]
es ist von Anfang an der Wurm drin
Autopanne schon noch ein Stück die
ersehnte Auszeit von Felix und Leon an
der Ostsee beginnt mühsam und dann auch
noch das hallo sie müssen das Haus mit
einer unbekannten
Teilen
[Musik]
meiner Mutter
leon ist genervt
und dann hat diese Nadja auch noch Sex
war es beginnt ein Sommer der großen
Gefühle ich muss jetzt was schreiben wo
es um
Begehren
sommerkörper Liebe geht und das darunter
Himmel ist aus diesem Gefühl heraus
entstanden dass die dort gekränkt werden
dass sie verlieben dass sie einsam sind
dass sie wissen dass das der Weg den sie
jetzt einschlagen werden ein furchtbar
sein könnte oder ein wunderbarer
doch Nadja gespielt von Paula Bär
entpuppt sich als zauberhaft Leon
wunderbar miese Petrich gespielt von
Thomas Schubert wehrt sich gegen so viel
Charme er muss schließlich arbeiten an
seinem so sperrigen zweiten Roman
ich habe ein Buch geschrieben
beziehungsweise ist das ein Manuskript
der Verleger findet scheiße da kommt
morgen vorbei
Petzold lässt ganz unterschiedliche
Charaktere aufeinanderprallen
jetzt ist schon zu gehen
in diesem flirrenden Sommer am Meer
kommst du nicht mit
nein
Film voller Humor in dem aber immer auch
etwas Tragisches mitschwingt
während bei allen die Gefühle
hochschlagen lodert um sie herum der
Wald und die Flammen kommen näher
kriegen das Feuer nicht unter Kontrolle
Endzeitstimmung macht sich breit die
Feuer im Film Originalaufnahmen denn in
der Nähe des Filmsets brannte der Wald
tatsächlich ich habe das Gefühl dass sie
dass sie diesen dass diese Sommer so
kostbar werden weil sie vielleicht die
letzten sind und vielleicht ist diese
schönheitlichung Wald mehr
Unbeschwertheit Sommer Jugend vielleicht
ist das in wirklich großer Gefahr am
Ende des Sommers wird für Petzold
Figuren nichts mehr so sein wie es war
roter Himmel auf der Berlinale mit dem
Großen Preis der Jury ausgezeichnet ist
ein Film voller Gefühl und Atmosphäre
leicht und schwer zugleich mit
großartigen Darstellern macht alles oder
[Musik]
das was von uns mit Kino geht es auch
gleich nach dem Wetter erstmal weiter
mit dem ZDF montagskino und um 23:45 Uhr
[Musik]
guten Abend es gibt ja Menschen die
schon am Montag gerne auf das nächste
Wochenende schauen das lohnt sich vom
Wetter her tatsächlich denn die ganze
Woche über haben wir es mit diesem Hoch
zu tun das weiter Richtung Grünland
sieht dabei wird es bei uns erstmal kalt
werden aber zum Ende der Woche dreht
dann die Strömung zwischen einem Tiefe
dem Atlantik und dem Hoch hier östlich
von uns auf Südwest und dann wird es
wärmer aber der Reihe nach heute Nacht
fällt erstmal Regen zwischen
Niedersachsen und Sachsen und auch am
Alpenrand und die Temperaturen sinken
auf 6 Grad im Thüringer Becken oder am
Oberrhein und bis 0 Grad in der Eifel
oder im Hunsrück und morgen liegen dann
die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 7 Grad
in der Oberpfalz und maximal 17 Grad am
Oberrhein und das Wetter wird doch recht
wechselhaft sein am freundlichsten ist
es im Norden Schleswig-Holsteins da
scheint die Sonne strahlen sonst
überwiegen die Wolken und hin und wieder
kann es auch ein bisschen regnen
besonders in der Mitte und im Süden
Deutschlands der Winter zu weht lebhaft
und zwar aus ost-nordöstlichen Richtung
am Mittwoch drohen dann Schneeregen und
Graupel Gewitter hier im Nordosten bei
einem kräftigen Wind aus Nordost der
Donnerstag bringt uns dann Schneefälle
zumindest mal in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen oberhalb von 400 bis 600
Meter und der Freitag wird dann schon
deutlich milder und sonniger und wie sie
hier am Wetter und Temperaturen Trend
für Erfurt sehen können wird es am
Samstag sogar noch wärmer danach
allerdings sinken die Temperaturen
gleich wieder guten Abend